-I'm so very happy
that you are here.
It's impossible for me to not
picture you as Princess Margaret
in "The Crown," now.
This is a role you almost did
not get though, is that correct?
-Yes, actually. I had quite
a strange screen test.
I nearly -- nearly ruined it
for myself.
-You nearly blew it?
You're putting this on yourself?
-I nearly blew it.
-What'd you do?
-Well, it was my birthday.
-Okay.
-And I was having birthday lunch
with my friends.
I was going out in these, like,
quite bad dungarees.
Anyway, as I was walking
out of the house,
I did a double take in the
mirror and I thought,
"Oh, my ankles looks so pale."
And it was, like,
a summer's day.
So I sort of whacked on some,
like, instant, sort of,
fake tan I found
in my sister's drawer.
-This is because you didn't want
to have bad looking ankles
on your birthday?
-Yes. I mean, come on.
-Yeah, okay.
We've all been there.
-We've all been there.
-Yeah.
-You want to have birthday
ankles. It's your day.
Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-Like, they've got to be
sun-kissed for whatever reason.
So I, kind of, like,
slapped it on -- slapdash.
Very slapdash
and then went to my screen test
and I borrowed some of mum's
ill-fitting skirts
and, like, pearls just to look
a little bit Margarety.
And I changed, and I just forgot
about the ankles.
[ Laughter ]
And I walked into my screen
test,
and, um, all four of the
directors and Peter Morgan,
the creator, just went
straight to my ankles.
Because I was wearing
this skirt,
and they were looking at them
for about ten minutes
as I was trying to
get into character
and I was trying to be Margaret.
And then I looked down,
and eventually Peter said,
"Look, what has happened
to your legs?"
And it was a fast-developing,
very strong, kind of,
industrial fake tan.
[ Laughter ]
So, they were like luminous
orange.
-So you had, sort of, a regular
colored leg into the --
-Very pale.
-Okay.
-Into, like, what?
Did it look like a sock?
-Yeah, sort of,
fluorescent football sock.
-Okay.
-I'd say. Yeah.
-So, a very strange choice for
a member of the royal family.
-Do you know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-I mean, Peter said --
I mean, honestly,
I think he looked at my ankles
more than my face
for the whole hour.
And he said it nearly
cost me the job.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-Well, I'm glad you
persevered through that.
-I know. I pushed through.
-Yeah.
The great actors always have
to handle
bad self-applied tanning
at some point.
[ Laughter ]
-At some point, it happens.
Doesn't it?
-It happens.
It happens to the best of it.
-It happens to the best of us.
And that was an early --
that -- I haven't used
fake tanner since.
-When he auditioned for
"There Will Be Blood,"
Daniel Day-Lewis,
crazy-bad fake tan.
-Is that true?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, Seth, I'm incredibly
gullible.
-Yeah. Oh,
I'll keep that in mind
and enjoy the rest of this
interview.
[ Laughter ]
So, you -- this is a --
because you play a royal,
and this time where people
are obsessed with royals
because of the wedding,
do people, sort of, assume
that because you play one on TV,
that you have extra intel
into the royal family?
-I mean, all the time.
People are like.
"so, how do you think Harry
feels with the roast chicken
and Meghan?
How do you think he did it?"
I'm like, "Well, I played
his great aunt in a show.
I think -- I'm sure he's
overcome with emotion."
And the Queen,
I mean, all of them.
-But you did -- you fell in love
with Princess Margaret, yes?
-Quite right.
-You really did.
-Too obsessed.
You so obsessed that you --
you framed a picture of her
and the Queen and put it
in your bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
So, now people who go in
this bathroom know that
that's someone you play
on a TV show.
-I know. Most people don't,
I don't think.
-Oh.
-And they just think I'm
just obsessed with the Queen
on horseback
on the front cover of "Tatler."
-Yeah.
-The thing is, is what happened
was I got so nervous
before playing her,
I just was like,
I need to order every
picture I could find.
And, like,
put it all over my house,
and then somehow when I wake up
or when I wee --
You know what I mean?
Like absorb her personality.
-Oh, wow.
-Gradually by osmosis.
-Oh, so you don't want to lose
a single moment.
-No.
-Yeah.
-And why?
I mean, they both look dreadful.
-Yeah.
-Sorry Queenie,
but you don't look great.
-I do have a question.
Is this -- is this you
in the mirror?
-That was my mum.
-Oh, that's your mom trying --
[ Laughter ]
So, she's
-That's my mum.
She hates pictures.
Oh, she's gonna be so
embarrassed.
But look.
Like a creepy stalker.
-By the way no one's
going to be like,
"That's a terrible picture
of your mom."
You can't even tell it's her.
[ Laughter ]
-Also, by the way, that was
the tea towel from my kitchen.
She put it in to make the loo
look nicer.
-Oh, really?
-There's not usually
anything there, yeah.
-Did you say,
"Hey, I need you to take
a picture
of this for television?"
-I did, yeah.
-And then she said "Okay,
I'm gonna --
I'm gonna spruce it up."
-She drove 'round --
She drove 'round to my house
and took it.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-She's like my life.
-Oh, that's great.
Well, it's -- she's obviously
not a professional.
[ Laughter ]
But I think she did
a really good job.
-That's, like, not even an eye.
Yeah.
-I mean, it's fantastic.
And obviously it's a place --
who wouldn't want
that as a bathroom?
-You think so?
I think I need to take it down.
-I think you -- yeah,
you maybe need to, like --
or put, like, something else
up to complement it.
-What should I put?
-I don't know.
-Maybe I do.
-But maybe some --
Definitely don't put someone
you've played on TV.
-I know.
-Like, don't make that dramatic.
-It's kind of cringe, isn't it?
I mean, she's all over my house.
Like my DVD collection.
-Is it also --
'cause you live with
your sister?
-And my best friend.
-And your best friend.
And do you also -- is it true
that you make them listen
to music that Princess Margaret
listened to?
-Yeah. I know, terrible.
-So, what did she listen to?
-So, she has this desert island
disc on YouTube.
I really recommend it.
I'm such a desperate fan.
It's quite embarrassing.
[ Laughter ]
So she talks about
her favorite music.
And one is "Scotland the Brave"
on the bagpipes.
So I'd blast it out on a Sunday.
[ Laughter ]
It was like rah,
rah, rah, rah, rah!
Like that, literally.
And my sister is, like,
waking up to it at 9:00 a.m.,
like, "Please, dear God. I hate
having an actress as a sister."
And then, like,
none of them are actresses.
But they put up with me.
And like, the DVD collection
is like "Royal Family,"
"The Royal Wedding,"
"The Queen at 50."
You know, "Margaret and Peter."
It's just really --
It's pathetic.
-And do you watch it a lot?
-To reminisce and, like, cry
over it.
[ Laughter ]
My sister.
-This is very exciting.
You are doing a show
in London right now.
"Julia."
-"Julie."
-"Julie," sorry.
-No, no. It's okay.
-Oh, I saw you in "Julia."
It was not as good,
so I'm glad you've moved on
to "Julie."
[ Laughter ]
So, I probably just --
but there was --
I always am fascinated by things
that happened during live
performances of shows.
You had something that you
would not have predicted
happening in a performance
of "Julie."
-Yes. It was one
of the first previews.
And someone in the circle --
or the balcony.
At the end when everyone
was clapping, they had a fight,
and a man tried to push
another man off it
while they were clapping.
I was like, "Was it me?
[ Laughter ]
Was it something I did?
Is it something I said?"
Maybe they hated it.
But, yeah.
It was all over the news.
-So, it was, like,
during the applause?
And nobody ever figured out
what the conflict was?
-No, it was just two guys.
-Wow.
-Like a big bust up.
-It doesn't seem like you
would go get wasted
and go see "Julie."
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
I know. Maybe they were just,
like, glugging it down.
glugging something down
during it.
Or maybe they just --
I just -- in fact,
what was the fight about?
-Yeah.
All right. But, hopefully --
Please come back,
and hopefully we'll get to
the bottom of that,
'cause maybe we'll have
those guys on as well,
and we can both ask them.
-Do you know what?
They'd probably -- yeah.
-They'd probably love it.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
Probably wouldn't talk about
Margaret so much.
-That is true. Hey, thanks
so much for being here.
It's such a pleasure
to meet you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Vanessa Kirby everybody.